"Welcome im 'Leberkäsesemmel to go'-Store, was darf es denn sein?"
"Zwei Leberkässemmeln, bitte!"
"Auf Roggen-, Weizen-, oder Roggen-Weizen-gemischt- Semmel?"
"Weizensemmel!"
"Leberkäse rot oder weiß?"
"Rot."
"Kalt oder frisch aus der Mikrowelle?"
"Frisch."
"Mit Senf, Ketchup oder ohne?"
"Senf."
"Mit süßem oder scharfem Senf?"
"Scharfem Senf."
"Zum Mitnehmen oder zum hier Essen?"
"Mitnehmen."
"In Alufolie einwickeln oder gleich in die Tüte?"
"Tüte."
"Braune oder weiße Tüte?"
"Oder doch in Alufolie!"
"Die glänzende Seite der Alufolie nach außen oder nach innen?"
"Ja leckt mich doch am ...! Ich geh wieder!"
"Wollen Sie vorne raus oder hinten?"
"Ja, rutsch mir doch den Buckel runter!"
"Nur runter oder auch wieder rauf?"